[MUSIC PLAYING]
ALI AFSHAR: Hi, everyone.
Welcome to Google
Developers Live.
We're going to be talking today
about the Google Drive
SDK and specifically how you can
use various parts of the
Google Drive user interface
to drive users to your
application and to make your
application more useful.
So when we set about writing the
Google Drive SDK, our main
goal was to allow you, the
developer, to be able to write
applications that are as good
and as fully-featured as the
Google Docs applications.
That's Google Docs spreadsheets
presentations.
That's what we're
aiming to do.
So one of the steps we recently
made was a huge step
towards this, and it's
the Create menu.
And I don't know if you've seen
on Google Drive, there's
a Create menu, and you click
it to create new documents.
Well, we've added the ability
for your applications to
appear there.
And I'm joined today with
Greg, who's going to go
through this and show us
some of the things.
So Greg, if we could look at
Google Drive and look at the
Create menu.
GREG KNOKE: Yes, if we can
go to my computer.
OK.
So here you'll see the
Create button.
So if you click on the Create
button, on the left you have
the original Google
Drive docks types.
And you can see here I've
already got one app installed,
Lucidchart, which is a really
fantastic diagramming tool.
So if we click on Lucidchart,
you'll see that we
go to the app page.
And while we wait
for it to load--
here we are.
So it's loading.
You can see we've got
Lucidchart up.
Just make a new document, and
let's just add a couple little
things to it here.
And now if I go back to Drive,
you'll see that the document
has already appeared
in my Google Drive.
ALI AFSHAR: OK.
So that's really awesome.
So with one click, the user is
being directed to Lucidchart.
You've created the file, and
then it's there in your Drive
for you to access from
all your machines.
OK, fantastic.
So if we could then look
at that Lucidchart
file in your Drive.
If you right click on that--
GREG KNOKE: Right.
Then we have this Open With
feature, so we can open the
document with Lucidchart.
Or if we had other apps that
could open this document type,
which this is a proprietary
document type, so there are
none in this case.
But say the PDFs, we could do.
You can see we might have a
couple more options for
opening this type.
And if I had some sort of PDF
viewer app installed, we would
see it there.
ALI AFSHAR: If you click on it
to Open With, can you show us
what happens there?
GREG KNOKE: Yeah.
So if we click on the Open With
Lucidchart, you'll see
that we, again, open this
document directly into
Lucidchart.
ALI AFSHAR: OK.
So that's great.
So is there any way I can get
more apps or how would that
happen there?
GREG KNOKE: So also you'll see
here at the bottom of the
Create menu, we have
Connect More Apps.
So let's just go find another
app to connect to Drive.
There's one in particular
we were looking for.
ALI AFSHAR: So while you find
that-- so this looks a bit
like the Chrome Web Store, and
that's because it's leveraging
the same technology as
the Chrome Web Store.
GREG KNOKE: Right.
So here we found Cacoo, another
diagramming app
because maybe I want
some other feature
that only Cacoo has.
So we'll install it,
and you'll see I
just clicked Install.
I was prompted, and it's
still loading.
This'll take just a second.
There we go.
So it's connected now.
And now, if you see, I click
in the Create menu
and Cacoo is here.
So let's go create
a Cacoo document.
ALI AFSHAR: So obviously,
there's authorization.
The app has to be granted
authorization by you, but that
only has to happen once.
GREG KNOKE: Right.
ALI AFSHAR: The first time?
GREG KNOKE: Oh, an error
has occurred.
OK.
So we'll try that again.
See if it works this time.
OK.
There we go.
So now you can see I had
previously installed this, but
we'll just make a
new document.
So we'll just start a new
Cacoo document here.
There we go.
ALI AFSHAR: This is another
diagramming app?
GREG KNOKE: Right.
So here's another diagramming
app, Cacoo.
You can see it's the same
idea as Lucidchart.
And let's just go ahead and save
this diagram, and so now
the diagram is saved.
And if I go back to Drive
and refresh here--
well, this one hasn't
saved to Drive yet.
I'm not sure why that happened,
but eventually,
Cacoo's document will show
up here as well.
ALI AFSHAR: OK.
So that's awesome.
So you can create and open files
with these applications,
and you can install these
applications.
And great for your users as
they don't have to leave
Google Drive to actually
install this stuff.
It can all happen in there,
in Google Drive.
So now I've installed
these applications.
Really important is, how do
I remove them and how do I
manage them?
GREG KNOKE: So say you decide
you don't really need an
application anymore
for some reason.
Here, I'll go back
a step here.
You see the little gear here.
If you click on the Settings
gear and then go to Manage
Apps and bring up the
Application Manager.
ALI AFSHAR: Could you show us?
Go through there and tell
us what's in there?
GREG KNOKE: So in here, you
have all the different
applications you've installed
to your Google Drive.
So you see I have a few, like
PicMonkey and Lucidchart, that
are already installed, and
Cacoo, which I just installed.
So then you have options.
You can view the product page.
You can view all the files that
the app is authorized to.
You can look at the files
this app has created.
Or, if you decide you don't need
the app anymore, you can
just disconnect it from Drive.
And so, if we disconnect it
from Drive, you see it
disappears from the list of
available applications.
Click OK.
But this won't actually delete
the files that this
application has created
from your Drive.
ALI AFSHAR: So exactly.
You don't lose your data.
What it does is it removes
all the authorization.
It is equivalent to you revoking
the tokens, so the
app can't access those
files anymore.
But they're there if you ever
want to use them again.
You can just re-install the
application if you want to.
So that's really great.
Bring your application
in front of all the
Google Drive users.
Put it there, put the icon
there, and make it easy for
people to click.
Make it easy for people to
use your application.
How do you do it?
OK, that's kind of
really important
but also really easy.
A lot of these web applications
have a Chrome Web
Store listing.
If you don't have a Chrome Web
Store listing, I kind of want
to know why because it's the
perfect fit for your
applications that
create stuff.
All you have to do is add a
couple of values into your
Chrome Web Store manifest.
And those are the container
value, which has
to be Google Drive.
So you add that container
value.
And then you need to link your
project ID as well, so we know
that the right project is
having the authorization
details and that
kind of thing.
OK?
So it's very, very easy.
If you go to Google
Developers--
sorry, developers.googl
e.com/drive/listing, that is
where you can find information
on this and
simple copy and paste.
But you just add a couple of
lines to your manifest, and
magically, you'll appear
in this list.
I would think that
this is a really
advantageous thing to do.
It's not something you do at
the start when you're first
building your app.
But when it's good, when it
works, when it's polished, put
it there, and people will be
able to find your app.
If you look back on some of our
previous videos, so like
at Google I/O, they show that
there are a few case studies.
My advice-- there was one in
particular who said that not
only were they getting more
conversions coming from Google
Drive, but these people were
more premium users.
They were more likely to
pay for services and
that kind of thing.
So I would think that it's a
really, really good thing for
you to do to promote your app
as a marketing exercise that
really works.
So that's mostly us.
Let's see if we've got any
questions that asked.
OK, great.
I see no questions,
so I assume that's
all perfectly clear.
It's kind of obvious, really.
Have you got anything
to add, Greg?
GREG KNOKE: I have nothing
to add right now.
I think you explained
it all very well.
ALI AFSHAR: OK, brilliant.
So thanks, everyone.
Get in touch with us on Stack
Overflow, on the Google Drive
Community, on Google+.
We're always happy
to talk to you.
We're always willing to look at
your applications and see
if you want to improve the flow
or polish it in some ways
because we're keen for the users
to be able to use this
stuff well.
OK?
So thanks very much.
Take care.
We'll see you next time.
GREG KNOKE: Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]